thomas alva edison
vous le connaissez le plus grands
inventeurs de tous les temps et selon
beaucoup de stoner le plus grand héros
de l'innovation
et pourtant savez vous qu'il a
électrocuté des chiens et pas que des
chiens il ait recruté des chats des
chiens
deux vaches ânes or en goûtant et même
un éléphant et dix on a fait tout ça
dans le cadre de ce qui est connu comme
la guerre des courants en fait il a
utilisé la technologie d son adversaire
westinghouse le courant alternatif pour
tuer ces animaux et prouver à la presse
que c'était une technologie dangereuse
qu'il fallait pas l'apprendre qu'il
fallait prendre sa technologie à lui le
grand direct et ils avaient tort ils
avaient tort sur toute la ligne
donc personne ne peut nier la
contribution des dix ans à notre société
et son énergie ses inventions ont fait
changer notre civilisation
il est un héros de l'innovation pourtant
on peut très bien se dire que cette même
énergie peut s'avérer très dangereuse
quand ils s'égarent quand l'idée rail
dont je me suis posé la question est il
possible d'empêcher ces héros de
dérailler peut-on établir un mode
d'emploi dont je vous invite aujourd'hui
faire un voyage au coeur des héros de
l'innovation pour essayer de trouver une
réponse et donc avec deux questions
tout d'abord qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
héros de l'innovation et ensuite quel
est son mode d'emploi d'emploi et vous
verrez bien le error il peut exécuter ce
mode d'emploi mais aussi son entourage
son chef ses collaborateurs son mentor
c'est très important parce que c'est
autant d'éléments qui vont être aussi
critique que le héros lui même pour que
les histoires d'innovation connu une fin
heureuse
mais commençons déjà avec la première
question qu'est ce que c'est un héros
d'innovation et je pensais connaître la
réponse parfaitement mon père et
scientifique et donc je suis tombé dans
la marmite quand j'étais tout petit et
en plus je travaille dans les domaines
depuis une douzaine d'années maintenant
et donc j'avais une idée plus ou moins
arrêtés dans la tête
un héros des l'innovation c'est un
passionné de la technologie qui arrive à
pousser un projet innovant contre la
volonté de sa hiérarchie
moi initial donc c'est certainement ça
une optique très innovations
industrielles et ça m'arrange est très
bien car je mets placés de façon
implicite dans cette catégorie et donc
quand j'ai commencé à préparer mon
intervention je me suis dit il faut être
un peu plus rigoureux donc j'ai pris un
tas des dictionnaires j'ai cherché des
définitions de héros des définitions
d'innovation j'ai mélangé le tout dans
un chaudron est la synthèse donc quelque
chose comme ça à éroder l'innovation
c'est une personne qui arrive introduire
un nouvel élément nouveau
technologie dans le marché la société un
surmontant des obstacles significatifs
qui se distingue par ses faits
exceptionnels
j'étais très content parce que ça venait
de confirmer l'idée que j'avais oui je
reste un héros très bien et pourtant je
n'avais fait que m'éloigner de l'essence
de la question donc il a fallu l'aide
une âme innocente
ma fille christine qui a cinq ans pour
me remettre sur le droit chemin et ça
s'est passé dans une scène tout à fait
banale mais j'étais en train de me
brosser les dents et christina tu es
avec moi et donc complètement obsédé par
la préparation de cette intervention
je n'aurais tourner vers christine
cristina est ce que toi tu sais ce que
c'est qu'un héros et le christina sa
robe de la reine des neiges au dessus de
ses piges à main n'a besoin que d'une
fraction de seconde pour rendre sa
sentence a bien sûr fait pas un héros
c'est quelqu'un qui veut sauver le monde
et là j'ai avalé mon dentifrice
lorsqu'il ya trois choses qui m'ont
beaucoup frappé dans sa réponse
d'abord le fait qu'une fille de 5 ans et
les une idée parfaitement arrêté de ce
que c'est qu'un héros au point de
pouvoir la rendre son réfléchir ensuite
et ne définit pas le héros parce qu'il
fait mais parce qu'il veut par sa
motivation
et finalement c'est une motivation un
twist donc quelques minutes de mûres
réflexions plus tard et après deux
verres d'eau pour faire passer de
dentifrice j'en tire deux conclusions
d'abord un erreur ça doit être un
élément vraiment critique dans la
société
et oui c'est un modèle c'est un exemple
qui dit à chaque individu de la société
regarde ce qui se passe si tu mets
l'intérêt de la communauté avant les
tiens si tu n'es pas égoïste si tu sert
une cause donc il s'agit d'une
motivation noble est un élément critique
qui raconte à travers des histoires et
c'est pour ça qu'une fille de 5 ans et
s'est déjà parfaitement ce que c'est
et donc si on compare ça avec la réalité
ce que ça tient
commençons par édition quelle était sa
motivation est donc si on regarde un peu
dans sa biographie ces citations
célèbres on trouve tout de suite une
phrase tout ce qui se vend pas je ne
veux pas en vente et savante épreuve
utilité et l'utilité les succès j'ai vu
ça c'est pas du tout la motivation que
je cherchais donc n'importe quel bon
scientifique j'ai ignoré les données je
continue à chercher mais rassurez vous
j'ai trouvé tout de suite j'ai trouvé
tout de suite
donc mon but principal dans la vie et
aider gagner assez d'argent certes mais
pour créer encore plus invention pour
sauver pour faire avancer la vie humaine
et pas par de la détruire
lueur d'espoir donc voilà une motivation
qui est bien plus noble et donc si nous
prenons le l'index les mentionner mighty
des plus grands héros de l'innovation
donc en un steve jobs on alexander
graham bell et anna marie curie donc
steve jobs je parlais de la pertinence
qu'il envie de faire ce que nous faisons
au service de quelque chose qui nous
dépasse
quand même un concept granby la il
parlait beaucoup moins mais on peut
constater très facilement à travers sa
biographie qu'en fait il a dédié sa vie
à aider les personnes malentendantes
le téléphone a une conséquence non
finalement
l'exemple qui nous tient le plus à coeur
au c'est vrai bien sûr marie curie
disait que nous ne pouvons pas
construire un monde meilleur sans
améliorer les individus et donc dans ce
but
chacun de nous doit travailler à son
propre perfectionnement tout en
acceptant dans l'avis général de
l'humanité sa part de responsabilité ça
a été difficile à prendre cette phrase
mais c'est une phrase qui est vraiment
très noble et donc on peut vraiment dire
qu'il ya un but noble qui a animé les
plus grands héros de l'innovation
donc c'est l'idée de servir à l'humanité
de servir la société à travers une
innovation à travers une activité
d'innovation
donc on va appeler ça le feu sacré
fêterait héros et donc il y a des choses
intéressantes dans ce feu sacré ya deux
choses tout d'abord ce feu sacré qui
l'animé
ces personnes à surmonter des obstacles
insurmontables pour lui nos moteurs
honda à faire des sacrifices jusqu'au
point de laisser leur vie au passage la
première chose c'est que ce n'est pas un
feu exclusif nous pouvons tous accéder à
ces feux très facilement si on va
innover
il suffit juste de chercher une cause
noble la pure suivre au lieu de chercher
une technologie qui nous semblent cool
il regarder à quoi ça sert
la deuxième chose qui est très
intéressant de ce feu c'est de ça vient
avec un cadeau un cadeau dans une au
sens grec du terme
le charisme car y'a rien de plus
charismatique que le mélange de force
des calmes des déterminations qui vient
commencé qu'on est en train de servir
une cause qui est plus noble et plus
grande que soi même et ça aide à une
nouvelle aussi et puisqu'on parle des
grecs
on va dire c'est pas une idée nouvelle
aristote parlait déjà à l'époque relève
des mots ni pour les lèvres des moyens
c'était le but ultime but ultime la fin
la plus haute de tout être humain il
animait tout le monde à la chercher
c'est mieux que le bien-être mieux que
la justice et donc il disait chacun peut
aller vers ce n'est les moyens à travers
ses actes ses tâches
ce qu'il appelait son ergon et aristote
is est un homme qui connaît son
hégémonie et qui choisit un ergot adapté
à ses capacités va vivre une vie
beaucoup plus heureuse c'est beaucoup
plus accompli que le reste des mortels
donc dans le cas de ces héros
d'innovation de tous les rôles
d'innovation leaf démonia c'est cette
envie de faire avancer la société de
l'humanité lrgp ont leur tâche c'est
l'innovation car il s'agit de personnes
qui ont un goût pour la technologie qui
orieux citait pour la nature et pour la
science avec un concept aussi simple que
ça nous savons déjà ce qui fait marcher
le héros de l'innovation donc maintenant
imaginez que vous venez de recevoir un
héros de l'innovation tout frais vous le
sortez du carton vous voulez peut-être
de vous rendre compte que c'est vous
même car vous rentrez dans ces
définitions votre chez vous ou l'un de
vos collaborateurs
donc avant de le laisser partir on va
regarder le mode d'emploi
qu'est-ce qui peut dire ce mode d'emploi
félicitations vous venez de recevoir
héros de l'innovation son fonctionnement
interne et si simple quand même une
fille de 5 ans peut le comprendre son
potentiel pour votre département pour
votre société et pour la société est
immense mais attention
wallin hartung cuidado à un roe de
l'innovation mal accompagné peut
représenter un danger pour soi même et
pour son entourage
ne le laissez pas sous surveillance en
compagnie de chats chiens vaches
or en goûtant éléphants et meilleur
respecter ces trois consignes de
sécurité pour maximiser le potentiel de
votre héros d'innovation et n'est pas
tombé dans d'effets secondaires
indésirables
donc petit 1 veillez bien à diriger
votre héros de l'innovation vers son but
ultime
car si on perd de vue les démonistes ce
pourquoi on innove on peut tomber dans
l'idolâtrie de la technologie dans
l'idolâtrie du moyen et là on a beau
être le plus grand héros d'innovation de
tous les temps on va se mettre à
l'écouté des chats est donc ce quai
dillon a fait c'est pas bien du tout il
a dépassé plusieurs lignes rouges il a
poussé sa technologie bien au delà du
raisonnable mais pourquoi ce qu'il a
fait ça
il était très attaché à sa technologie
trop attaché pour voir que la technique
technologies concurrentes que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui à propos et
servait aussi le même but
donc petit 2 veillez à garder un contact
avec votre antre à votre héros de
l'innovation et la réalité et 10 en lui
même il a commis cette erreur plusieurs
fois mais il ya beaucoup d'erreurs
d'innovation potentiel qui le fonde qui
commettent cette erreur tous les jours
et dont on n'entend jamais parler et on
peut les trouver
dont les bases de rêver c'est très
facile en fait mais dont je vais vous
montrer juste un exemple nous nous
trouvons unef démonia merveilleuse je
vais sauver le monde
je vais finir mais arrêtez la famine
dans le monde on retrouve un goût pour
la science et la technologie
pour ce faire je vais me servir de la
force de coriolis et par contre
exécution donc on va créer un réseau de
tuyaux des milliers de kilomètres entre
l'antarctique l'australie avec la force
de coriolis on va se tirer toute la
glace on va l'utiliser pour un rosé
l'australie on va faire pousser des
légumes qui vont nourrir le monde entier
c'est pas très local déjà fait un effort
d'innovation doit connaître quels sont
ses capacités
il doit savoir aussi ce qui est faisable
et alexandre granby les le savez à
l'époque il disait une personne qui agit
sans une fin pratique devient un fou ou
un idiot ce type de personnes
remplissent nos d'asile dernières
consignes de sécurité ne permettait pas
votre héros d'écrire son histoire en
avance car même si on garde bien en tête
ce pourquoi on line of même si on garde
le contact avec la réalité
il est toujours possible de dérailler et
je vois beaucoup d'innovateur tous les
jours y en a pas mal qui vient midi ces
personnages c'est un idiot
il comprend pas ce qu'on est en train de
faire qui comprend pas pourquoi on le
fait sur wii même lors d'une innovation
il a beau être le personnage principal
de son histoire il n'est pas le seul
d'ailleurs ça serait bien utile
si c'était le seul personnage donc il a
besoin d'autres personnes pour l'aider
ça peut être celui qui va financer son
start up c'est qui va construire son
prototype et on peut y apprendre un
quand car peut-être qu'ils sont les
héros de leur propre histoire et c'est
une histoire avec une belle eve des
moyens mais qu'avec un autre ergon donc
pas l'innovation mais quelque chose
d'autre un patron qui veut agrandir sa
boîte pour pouvoir donner à manger
pouvoir réduire le taux de chômage dans
la région
ça c'est aussi un but noble et donc il
s'agit pas de tout accepter
ralph waldo emerson disait être grand
c'est très bien compris et on peut pas
changer le monde sans un peu de conflits
mais on peut être un peu malin essayez
de tisser une tapisserie avec le fils de
notre histoire et les fils de ces autres
histoires aussi et on va retrouver une
histoire à la fin qui ressemble
peut-être pas du tout à ce qu'on avait
en tête
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas avoir une
idée complètement arrêtée parce que
cette histoire jeunes à garder en tête
le but ultime c'est pourquoi le faisait
si on est restés fidèles il va aussi
être une belle histoire d'innovation
l'histoire qui mérite d'être racontée
qu'on va s'arrêter là je vais juste vous
dire qu'on a besoin des road innovation
l'hérault d'innovation aussi besoin de
nous donc puisque je me suis permis de
citer ma fille je vais citer mon père
aussi et mon père qui me disait il ya
pas longtemps que le talon pour
accompagner les innovateurs c'est encore
plus rare et plus précieux que les
talons pour innover et donc veillons à
permettre à nos héros de garder en tête
c'est pourquoi ils innovent veillant à
lui permet de garder un contact avec la
réalité est aussi d'inclure les autres
personnes dans leur histoire
je compte sur vous
merci l'ars